well as we mentioned the race to 270
could really hinge on nevada but we're
not expecting final results at least now
we're told for a few days
orca mana joining us live from the clark
county election center in north las
vegas
and orco people want to know what is
taking so long waiting for those
additional results tomorrow morning
well ryan and denise a lot of it has to
do with the large number of votes
election workers here
and elsewhere have to go through the
nevada secretary of state's office
saying there are still roughly not 190
000 ballots
that need to be counted now a huge chunk
of those about 90 percent are here in
clark county
the clark county elections department
saying it's counted 51 000 votes today
alone
we're also waiting on thousands of mail
ballots registrar of voters joe gloria
telling us the bulk of those will be put
into the system
by this weekend but all mail ballots
postmarked by election day and received
by november 10th
will be counted gloria also says the
goal is not to be fast
but to be accurate since all eyes are on
nevada right now
that's why election workers are counting
ballots from roughly 5 a.m
to 11 p.m daily but not overnight
we don't run the 24-hour shifts that you
see running in other states because
the work that comes through on the mail
ballot process is very deliberate as it
moves forward
and so we complete the work that's done
in each stage and then the next day it
carries forward to the next
those steps include processing the
ballots matching the signatures
and tabulating the results gloria adds
counting ballots is a little bit of a
slower process because nevada
has never handled mail-in votes of this
scale before
again the race between joe biden and
president trump is still too close to
call here in nevada
with biden up only about 12 000 votes
again we're expecting updates from both
the state
and the county tomorrow morning
reporting live in north las vegas
tonight orco mana 8 news now